(electronic music)
- Oh, hello.
- Are you here for the party?
You're a little early,
but, the early bird
get the wormy-worm.
- And that's code for schvantz.
- You know what
Lou Reed once said?
- Get out of my bedroom, you
guys are masturbating in here
and this is my home.
- You're probably thinking
that's too much tuna.
- I'm not thinking anything, no.
- I think it's great.
- You ticked off?
- It's a lot of tuna.
- What's the meaning of this?
- Smells like tuna in here.
- This is probably
too much tuna.
- The tuna's perfect.
- You're on a prank show
called Too Much Tuna, Jeff,
whether you like it or not.
- No I'm not.
- So Geeg, should
we stretch first?
- Nah, let's just stay
tight and get injured.
- If you have an
orthodontist in here,
I've been using a couple
Chiclets as teeth in the back.
- When I drink too
many capuccinis
my penis becomes useless.
- Can I have
bagel-induced cholesterol?
- I need you guys to go.
- Jerk him off.
(electronic music)